Hello and welcome
to the Rawkode Academy and today's episode of
Rawkode live. Today, we are taking a look
at Docker's BuildKit and BuildX.
Now before we do that, there's a little
bit of housekeeping. First and foremost, please subscribe
to the channel,
tick that bell and you will get notifications
for all new episodes of Rawkode Live and
Clustered and everything else in between.
Also check out the membership options if you
wanna take advantage of some of the courses
that we have coming out on the academy.
Currently, are working through the complete guide to
InfluxDB
two.
Also, we have a very active Discord server
available at Rawkode.chat.
There's over 500 of us in there talking
Docker, Cloud Native, Kubernetes and everything in between.
So come on, say hello, and I look
forward to meeting you.
Okay. Today's session, BuildKit and Buildx.
I am joined by Thomas Tighe, a maintainer
of BuildKit and an engineer at Docker. Hi
there, Thomas. How are you? Hi, David. How
are you?
I'm doing alright. Thank you. Can you just
for anyone who is not familiar with you,
although I'm sure they have all seen your
GitHub avatar on every repository in the Docker
ecosystem.
But just tell us who
you are and a little bit about you,
please.
Yeah. So I work at Docker. I'm a
I've been, like, a Docker maintainer for quite
some long time.
Think bunch of different stuff there in the
early days, like
like some some storage
stuff and
and d and the ones working integrations.
And and the last years, I've been,
like, more looking at the build side.
So I started with
with the multistage builds that's
happened, like, a couple of years ago already.
And then
and then, like, kind of, like, boost up
the BuildKit project and later on, like, BuildKit
project as well for
And
yeah. I got I guess that that that's
where if if you've seen my amateur, then
then these are probably probably the repositories there.
Awesome. Well, thank you for that.
So, yeah, multistage builds were just awesome. I
think everybody makes so excited with that. And
then the BuildKit projects just seems to be
bringing more and more functionality
to to what we need to build our
images in an efficient and, you know, super
cashed way.
But for anyone who's not sorry. Let me
go.
Yeah.
Hope they're going in in in the same
direction. Like, it's it's a it's just like
I guess it takes a little bit time
for for, like, the main mainstream
places to catch up. So we are, like
at the moment, like, very loud. If I
if I look at the, like, the
Dockerfile talks or something like this, then, like,
every every talk is, like, multistage builds. So
it's like but, like, actually, it's, like, happened,
like, already, like, a three years ago. So,
hopefully, like like
like, in in a year or or two,
we will see, like or 50 to have,
like, a synchronous session.
Nice.
Okay. So let's
break down the two different components we're we're
looking at today. We're gonna be looking at
something called BuildKit and something called BuildX.
Can we just explain what both of those
are to the audience?
Sure. Sure. So
so,
of course, like, Docker itself has always had,
like, a mount well, sorry, like, a build
endpoint. Right? So the there's Docker Docker build
command. Everyone knows about it. It has been
there for the beginning.
So what BuildKit is is basically, like, rethinking
the the background component of this from break,
like, ground up, and it's done in a
separate project so that so that not only
Docker can use it and
and
and we can, like,
basically, like, rethink, like, what it what it
means to have, like, a cool builder in,
like, a modern container ages.
And and
one thing for maybe or not about BuildKit
is that might be a little bit confusing
is that if you're just, like, building images,
you don't necessarily need to care about BuildKit
itself that much. Like, it's more like an
internal tool. It's more like builder.
But if you're, like, building your own builders,
if you're, like, developing a language and want
to make sure that it builds fine in
in containers. If you want to, like, contribute
to BuildKit and things like that, then you
then you would look at BuildKit.
If you're just building images,
you're probably just using a tool that's using
BuildKit under the hood like like Docker or
or or, like, there there's tons of other
other ones as well. So
although although, like, sometimes we, like, use BuildKit
also as, like, an umbrella term to just,
like, talk about, like, the it's like a
modern stack or something like this. But but
but yeah. Mostly, it's like a back end
back end component. It's very important for making
all the builds efficient and all those things.
Not necessarily something that, like, a user actually
needs to care about.
Alright. Awesome. And can we tell people what
BuildKit is then?
So, yeah, the BuildKit is more like a
Docker side of
of a
component where we
we like
where we develop our, like, Docker UI for
for the build. So these were, like, the
Docker Docker user experiences.
Like, on BuildKit side, we're, like, very generic.
We just we don't want to be opinionated
or anything like this. We just want to
provide the back end that that works for
everyone, for for every use case. In build
BuildKit side, we're taking, like, the Docker user
experience that
the the users know and just tries to,
like,
add add new stuff when it build on
top of it.
BuildKit itself is like a CLI plug in
for Docker. So it comes with Docker. It's
like a Docker command, but it's actually, like,
a stand alone binary.
So we can develop it separately and and
in addition to
to, like, just like a build command, there's
also, like, a ton of other command required.
I'm sure we we get into there, but
what what what's in there, but, like, build
exit. But when the old build command is
just, one build command, Then build exit, like,
10 commands or something like that. So it
it, like, it provides a lot lots of
other use cases that that weren't there initially.
Nice. Well, we will be playing with both
of these in just a minute so people
will get to to see them hands on,
which would be awesome. I think there's just
one more thing I'd like to kinda talk
about before we move into the hands on
component.
And before I say that, if anyone has
questions in the audience, please drop them into
the chat. We'll keep an eye on it,
and we'll do our best to answer them
as we go.
Okay. So my final question.
BuildKit.
Like, it just I don't I don't know
if it's just me. I wonder if you
feel the same from your side, but the
adoption of BuildKit across other tooling seems to
be the velocity of that just seems to
be going really fast. Like, I see BuildKit
being used as like a a cache or
a build layer for so many different projects
from, like, Dagger to Airfleet.
Is that something that you're seeing a lot
of uptake on as well?
Sure. And, well, like,
from my side, I'm I'm glad that it's
happened because, well, that that's what it was
meant for. Like, it's it's it's kind of
like
the standard, like,
when when we're, like,
doing any kind of build flows and, like,
including
containers in there, there's definitely, like, this shared
part, that's common part that's, like that's actually
very hard to develop, very hard to get
right. And, like and it doesn't make sense
for, like, every tool out there to try
to invent their own. Like, that that's how,
like,
the, like
even, like, the old Docker build, like, it
did something, like, just for for their use
case. So, like, didn't quite think of it
maybe true in the in the first first
version and, like, ended up something that's, like
some some cases work for Docker, didn't really,
like, allow further development, didn't in fact for
everyone anyone else. So, like,
so, yeah, that that's what BuildKit is for.
Like, like,
anytime you use
some kind of, like, a container as build
flow and you need caching support, you need
to need to be fast. Like like like,
that that's what you should be using.
Okay. Thank you. Alright. Well, let's get my
screen shared and try and work out what
we're going to do today.
So I've got the BuildKit repository here,
the BuildX repository here.
I have a local directory with two projects
that I'm familiar with, one in Go and
one in Rust,
and we have a shared Versus Code live
session so that we can both type as
we try to explore this.
So I believe what we're gonna do is
maybe start with a goal project, the blocks,
and try and take a look at some
of the new features that BuildKit exposes to
make our build system cache efficient
using multi stages and other things. I just
tried to explore some of these features that
BuildKit brings to the table.
This thing good?
Sure. Sure. Let's start with that one. Alright.
So here's the fun bit. Oh, well, thing.
And currently blocks doesn't build inside of a
Docker file. We
use GoReleaser and let's change that. So we're
gonna attempt to build our Go application and
a Docker file using a multistage builds
and take advantage of as much caching stuff
as we can as possible.
And I've heard a rumor as I've not
been able to try it yet that we
have the ability to build binaries out and
put them on the local machine and stuff.
So we're we're gonna try and explore this
and and get your knowledge and experience along
the way as we go to.
Sure. Sounds sounds good. Yeah. Yeah. Like, this
kind of Docker file definitely feels like that.
The biggest thing we can do in in
Docker files, like like like, if if if,
like, anyone watching this learns one thing, then,
like, don't don't, like, put binary or, like,
copy binary in in some type of time.
Yeah. We could we could definitely improve this.
So but Yeah. So so, yeah, like, I
assume, like, this one, you
you
you call it from, like, a make file.
Right? And and you you do, like, a
local go build and and then and then
you call Docker build after that there. Like,
if you look at
Yeah. We've got
go build here. So yeah. Not not perfect.
Right? We we let's get this into a
container. So Yeah. And and what what's the
other one? The the other one was generating
talks or something like that.
Yeah. We have a command that generates the
documentation. Yeah.
Well, we'll see where where we get to.
But we we can we
can maybe do something for this one as
well. Yeah. Alright. Awesome. We got some love
for BuildKit speak in the chat. So
we'll take a look at that as we
go, I'm sure.
And we have a couple of questions already.
I don't know if you wanna tackle them
now or not, but let's I'll let's mention
them and then you can decide if we
tackle them now or you bring them in
later. So Russell is asking, I'm hoping we
can find out some juicy details. I've never
heard juicy and Docker used together, but I
like it, Russell. And something like cache being
unprotected and a good target for injecting extras
into images. I'm
not sure I understand that question, Russell. Do
you?
The last part, maybe maybe not.
I think we'll get to, like, yeah, like,
the remote caching. Like, we we can we
we we'll probably cover that as one as
well. But first, I think we need to
fix up this Docker file. Alright. Okay. I'll
let's just do that first. You're right. We
should.
So let's pull up our why can't I
see? There we go.
So I'm assuming we're gonna use a
multistage build here and maybe start with, like,
a a goal based image.
Yeah. I think we can, like,
just put, like, a goal and something in
here. Right?
Yeah. We're we can we can first do,
like, a very simple one. So, like,
that that's also
not good, but, like, show
that, like like, it's not that hard.
And basically do the same same whatever build
you had in here. Right?
I don't know. Or it's something like this,
sir.
Yeah. And let me just I think that
was pretty much spot on for the command.
I don't know if we do a Google
build command box, but I'll double check.
Yeah. I'll just copy this.
I see MD. Okay. Yeah. So we'll
need
okay.
So in theory,
this should actually give us the exact same
thing, but without a local build step.
Yes. Well, like, you have Ubuntu in here.
Like, I I just put Alpine because, like,
I I promote my stuff. But but,
yeah, like, that doesn't matter. Like, it could
be it could be Ubuntu in here as
well.
And yeah. And and, of course, like, the
benefit of this one is that
is that
whenever someone, like, check checks out your repository,
they don't need to have exact setup as
as you have. Right? Like,
don't need to do this part of the
build on the on the host and part
of it in the container. Like, everything is
in a container. Like, everything is defined by
by you as a project owner. You always
get the get the same same versions everywhere
and and things like that. Like, you can
even, like,
just be nice in here and definitely configure
about this. I
don't know if you use code to one
seventeen at there.
Oh, yeah. Well, it's, one sixteen minimum because
we do use go embed on this project.
So one seventeen, that'll be alright.
Okay. Yeah. I keep them even, like
again, if you want to, you could make
data, like, a best matrix, make this
changeable and and things like that. Right? So
but, of course, like,
what's what's bad about this one,
right, is that your source code is still
in here.
You have the whole cover on time in
here, things like that. Like, you don't you
don't want those. Right?
So so, yeah, let's let's make it on
this stage right away as well. Yeah. So
Alright.
It's a bit stupid then. Point point. Yeah.
And I I think that should be
enough for the first run. Right? Do we
want to try to build this on? Yeah.
Be rude if it's not to try it.
So
okay. I'm just gonna go sorry?
Yeah. We
can just click.
Maybe try BuildKit.
So Docker BuildKit build or, like, let us
foresee what what you do you have in
stock
in here in the in the system. Yeah.
Normally, I would just do Docker build. I'll
give it a fake tag for now and
then pass in my context as dot. Like,
you're telling me that we should evolve this
now?
Well, we we can let's let's let's let's
try and see what it does. Okay. This
one is a little bit messed up for
some reason.
For oh, it's just messed up for me.
I can see that the other stream is
correct. The in the in the in
the live share, it's it's a little bit
messed up. So, yeah, like, you can already
see, like, the
the
the BuildKit UI, like, that's a little bit
different than than what you had before.
Something is wrong because we copied to that
root in here.
We actually we got a a comment about
that just a second ago from Chris in
the chat. Good day, Chris.
And still not right. What what did we
do wrong?
You don't need
yeah.
That seems up here. There you go.
Okay.
Yeah. And and
yeah. So this should give you me, like,
a
quite smaller
image, and you already see, like, the BuildKit
UI in
here.
Let's let's cancel this one, and let's look
look at BuildKit right away. Otherwise, we're going
to, like, switch around a little bit. So
what I can do
in here, it's alright that there's a Docker
BuildKit command, hopefully, in your in your machine.
Yes. And that it is.
See what version this is.
Okay. This is, a little bit older version,
but
I I guess
I don't care. Or or or do we
want to update this? I can do it.
I I did tell it to download update
earlier today, but I guess it doesn't restart
it. So what I do
You want me to Actually, like, I'm not
sure if that's actually even even the like,
if you want to update, though, we can
we can get it just from GitHub, but
but I
I don't know it. Like, we probably won't
need anything anything from the new version.
Okay. I'm up to you. I don't know.
Well, let let's see. Let's
just continue. And then if we had a
wall with something because there's a a feature
that we're missing, we can talk about it,
and then we'll do the upgrade. The only
only thing that I can think of is
that maybe we if you get more error
messages then, like, the newer version has my
error messages.
But but
so what I want to show is in
here as well that there's
lots of command in here. Right? So there's
a build command.
Yeah. When I'm highlighting, of course, in my
screen, it doesn't show. But but, yeah, there's
there's a build command that's
pretty much the same command that that you
had there that was the old Docker build
command,
but there's bunch of other stuff in there.
Some people were asking about bake. Like, you
can see bake is in here.
There's there are options to create new builders
in here that
we would we'll probably get to if we
get to the multiplatform things
and and to manage those builders, manage build
cache with with
the disk usage and and things like that.
Maybe first thing we can do is just
look at the
Docker build x inspect.
That would just, like, show you what what's
the current, like, the builder that BuildKit is
or, like, the BuildKit is configured to use.
So you can see that it's using the
Docker drivers. So, basically, it's just using Docker
like a regular, like, or a Docker daemon
at the moment to do the builds.
We have the platform support because, like, those
those
come with Docker desktop.
So, potentially, we can, like, target all those
all those platforms.
Then we can basically we can do the
same
command that you did before. What what did
you name it? I just called it local.
Yeah. A terrible name, but I'll do.
So what's what's different between my build command
and this BuildKit build?
So
what's
what's different in here
is is
is is not very much because, like, by
default, like, build BuildKit will try to give
you, like, the exact same experience
as as you had before. So it was
still, like, building with Docker daemon so that
everything you build will be in your Docker
images and things like that.
But
what you get is these extra commands. So,
like, once we once we develop, then then
there's there's going to be a point where,
like, we have an option in here or
we have a we have a command that's
only in BuildKit, and you and you can't
use the same one in the in the
in the old command.
So,
basically, just
like, if you if you stick stick to
this flow,
then then you will go go much further.
Okay. You got a from
Crazy Max. I don't know if you know
anyone called Crazy Max, but there you go.
Yes. Indeed. Know.
And
just
to look at those commands.
One
more extra comment about this, like, BuildKit versus
or just Docker build is that if you
would run, like, this command, Docker build install,
then it will basically just, like, switch out
your Docker build command.
And and it like, you can you can
just try Docker build, and it will come
come come to BuildX.
I don't know if you're if you're ready
to do this or not, but we we
can we can skip this for now. Like,
you can you can make your decision later.
Yeah. I mean, is the is the goal
for BuildKit to replace build eventually?
Sure. Yeah. Sure. Okay. It's it's
I think it makes makes sense for the
user standpoint. Right? Like, sometimes you need to
sometimes you're using
you're building with Docker. Sometimes BuildKit also supports,
like, building, like, in Kubernetes or inside a
container and things like that.
Makes sense for the maintenance wise as well.
Like like, we we can develop build features
without, like, waiting for, like, a whole Docker
engine release and stuff like that.
Okay. Got it. So but but yeah. Like,
your image was built. Like,
if we're
yeah. I guess that's that's your command. Right?
Yes. That is indeed the blocks command there.
There you go.
Perfect.
So
how much time did it take? Do do
remember?
Like,
almost
almost a minute or something like that or,
like, even maybe maybe more. So
It took fifty two seconds. It's it's yeah.
Let's try to make it faster, probably.
One thing you can don't know if you
noticed if you're if you're on this command
or, like, maybe we could just make make
a simple change in here and just run
it again
is that
it installed your your dependencies in here. Right?
Yes.
Right. Because you don't have a vendor directory.
Correct.
So
yeah. Like, I'm I'm in the vendor camp,
but, like
well,
for sure, like, it it doesn't make sense,
for example, that when you when you were
building your your process in in a host,
right, then you get your audio caches and
stuff like that. Like, if you're if you're
on, for example, make a code change like
I did now and rebuild it, it doesn't
take you a minute anymore. Right? It only
takes you a minute on the first time.
So
I think we're gonna first figure out the
the dependencies thing
just to make this, like, just to clarify
a little bit better.
Right.
You mean, like, we could copy on the
GoMod and the GoSum first, run a GoMod
download, and then bring in the rest of
the source?
Exactly. That's what that's what I was what
I was thinking exactly.
So we can just put the go mod
in here
and then run, like, whatever it is. Go
mod download there. Yeah. Go mod download, I
believe, should be.
So so benefit of this one, right, is
that
we only download the dependency on the first
time. As long as you don't modify your
GoMod file,
then this step will always be cached,
and it will and
next time you make a Go change, only
only this one will run. It will already
have dependencies. It will not start to pull
them again.
Right.
Okay. So let's let's build that and get
the cache in place, and then we should
be able to confirm that that worked.
Sure.
Do I need to start this? Or
Yeah. I wasn't sure if we were still
modifying the Docker file or not there. Okay.
Yeah.
Alright. So let's do the download.
So
I guess in the meanwhile, can we already
start for the next steps? Or
it's like a
Yeah. I have a a question gonna be
able yeah. Go ahead. I have a question
that came in on on Twitter from Kieran.
Kieran asked, can I please ask Thomas about
how cache from and to are best used
in a CI environment where different branches are
all being built?
With the so I think the question there
is like,
are the different bells from the different branches
all using the same cash tag
or should you do something else?
Yeah. So
yeah. I'm not sure, like, if other people
will follow this question right away. It's very
specific. But
but yeah. Like, my
my
recommendation at the moment is to use the
different test tags for for
for, like, give different tags for for different
branches
so that they won't override each other.
If you get to that platform, like, there
there's, like,
many different ways how you can how you
can actually, like,
include the remote cache in our CI.
Like,
in some cases, for example, if you're using,
like, GitHub actions, I don't think, like, the
image cache is, you know, like, the best
option. Like, I I think, like, the there's,
like, a local caches, and and we have
some new GitHub caches there as well. Like,
that might might be even, like, a better
option there and
might, like,
solve this problem more elegantly. For example, like,
the GitHub caching, GitHub already provides you a
scoping for different branches, so you don't even
need to worry about this aspect at all.
So, yeah, like, this this one is now,
like yeah. It's it's fully cashed, but, like,
I can even make a change in here.
Right?
In
the in the Docker file.
And if I build it again,
then
the
the half of the build was was cached.
Right? So only, like, the binary is is
needed.
Let's cancel this. Yeah. But the but, of
course, like, the binary is still, like
binary stuff, they it takes too long time,
right, compared to your local one because, like,
the
Go added some kind of, like,
cool caching capability in the Google compiler. Right?
Like, when when you're running the Google compiler,
it will put some files in the in
the
in some directory, in your cache directory, and
that's why your next builds are faster. So
we can actually take leverage of this one
in Dockerfile as well.
So for that one so this is
not the multistage anymore. So this is only
in build
BuildKit now,
but it's, like, every version of BuildKit. So
run now allows some more track and
Oh,
I guess Thomas
dropped.
Oh, you're back.
Did I drop out there? Yeah. I'm not
sure what happened there. You just got it
it disappeared.
Yeah. My my my whole, like, tab crashed
for some reason. But
yeah. Alright.
Okay.
So
So in BuildKit, you're saying we can use
the dash dash mount tag, and then that's
kinda where you dropped off. Yeah. Okay. So
may maybe it's actually
makes sense to look at the documentation first.
Yeah.
So so that so that
we see something that we point
to a particular link.
Should have a link now. Yep. Got it.
So this one for
this document
list, like, some, like, additional things we've added
to. Like, there's there's some
cool things in here, like how you can
do
how you can do mounts, how you can
do, like, secrets
when you're cloning, like, private repositories,
how to, like, forward your
Recent version, we added here docs. So it's
just like a document where where you will
find, like, all all those described
that are, like, the new Dockerfile additions.
And one thing in here is that
basically
allows you to create mount points that are
available when your
when your process runs. So for example, like
a point, you can use just to, like,
point, basically, your build context to your to
your process
instead of making, like, a copy of it.
Like, the process can just directly see the
files.
In this case, like, a interesting one is
the cache one.
So this one just makes, like you can
think of it as a as a volume,
basically.
It's
it gives you a directory. You can write
into that directory.
The
if you run the build again
with the same cache mount,
the the files from a previous build will
basically be there. Uh-huh. So so you can
use this as, a persistent
anonymous storage
where you can, like that you can use
for for storing stuff for the for the
cache purposes. Of course, like like, this thing
is, like, excluded from your instruction cash, so
you need to be, like, careful about it
just to put things in there
that your process can actually handle. Like, basically,
like, you can put you
can put anything in there as long as
your process still works with basically any content
Because, like, like, cache cache volumes can can
be deleted in arbitrary times and, like, at
some other like, let's say you're you have
another build and it writes the same cache
volume, like like
so you can only use it for certain
things, but you can use it for the
things, for example, when when your compiler provides
a cache directory, then you can just, like,
use use this as a location.
And then your compiler will write there. You're
on the builder next time, and it will
get the files there as well.
Okay.
That makes a lot of sense. And I
can see there's there's a whole bunch of
there's also a a temp files system. There's
the the secret stores.
I got it. Like, for for the secret
one, for example, you can mount in secret
files. So we make sure that they're, like,
never stored in your image and and stuff
like that. And, like, on on as well.
And
and you can the other one is you
can mount the SSH
sockets in there. It's basically to to, like,
forward your forward your SSH agents.
Awesome.
So I had to correlate that back to
kind of what we're doing then with this
this go build here is that
we're doing a copy of the GoMod to
go some the GoMod download. That's that's just
basic image caching. Right? That's not using any
mounts or local
caching thingy.
Yes. Now is is that okay there? Or
is that something when you would probably just
encourage,
you know, to remove these two lanes and
then use a main type cache
and pull in the the gold cache?
Or does it not matter? Well, are
you saying that, like, if we have a
cache directory as well, then it doesn't really,
like, give us anything to to pull the
dependencies before?
But it actually it still it still does
because, actually, like, dependencies are not in in
the in the same location.
So what we can actually do is we
can do we can put another cache mount
in here.
Think it's co p k g. Right?
So so for example, like, next time this
command runs,
then
then it will pull the dependencies, but it
will pull it on the cache mount.
Yes. So do we even need to worry
about the copy of the go mod and
go to some anymore? Like, is that actually
bringing us any value, is that just,
like, the older way of doing things?
I
I guess
well, no. It's it's still like in certain
cases, it definitely brings us value because, like
like,
the
difference in here is that if your go
mode and go some have not changed, then
the builder will just keep over this command
completely.
Like, otherwise,
it will it will still run this command
and the goal itself will detect that. It
will need to compute some hashes of the
files, and then eventually, it will figure out
that, hey. I already have those dependencies and
stuff like that. Okay. Got it. So so,
like, it will be it will be faster,
but it won't won't be zero.
Right?
So so it it
still makes sense to have them in in
two.
This case, though, like, I guess, theoretically,
like, these lines
in here don't buy us anything because, like,
this go build will also
write everything in the in the code because
g one is doing this first slow build.
Right? Yeah.
So so, yeah, like, I'm I'm not sure,
like, if you want to keep this or
not. I think it It's It's I like
it. Questionable.
Yeah. One thing it might come back is
when
we
if we get to the multiplatform things,
then then
for example, let's say if we ever turn
this into
start to, like, cross compile or anything like
this to multiple platforms,
then this step in here that's pulling dependencies,
that is the same for for all the
platforms.
Like, if you're if you're if you're if
you're, for example, building for three platforms, this
command theoretically can run once while the compiler
needs to run three times.
So it might be like it might become
useful there. Yeah. Good catch.
Okay. So let's let's validate what you've just
changed here. So we're now mounting in our
our cache here for the dependencies and the
actual Google build cache. So what
what you're saying here is if we run
this,
we get a 52 build and then run
it again as even the Google build step
should be near
instant. Right?
Yeah. Or at least fast. It will it
be instant. It should be, like, pretty
much the same that you get on host
when you're when you're when you have all
your, like, specific Go setup setup in in
your host, like, everything is set up correctly,
and you're and you're, like,
have those persistent
folders in those. One thing here, we can
do an extra thing.
I'm not sure. Like, this copy probably was
super fast in here. So, again, it
yeah. I can see that it took, like,
zero point two seconds. So, like, I guess
it doesn't quite much make sense to optimize
it. But, you saw, there was a pipe
mount pipe bind there as well. Yeah. So,
basically, we could also do just, like, mounting
here,
bind is the default
to type. So
if do this, then you don't actually need
you may need a copy.
So then it would just mount our contact
into this
into this working directory.
And,
yeah, like, we will we will we will
not need to duplicate the data.
We'll like,
by default, it's it's read only as well
that might be issue. In some cases, I
don't think it's issuing here. But, basically, that
allows us to just,
like,
directly access those files.
So does that mean on on the whole
test.
So
I may sense early here, but I'm gonna
go on some of my things that I
think I know about Docker. Right? So when
we do the the build, we pass in
the build context, which is a dot. And
as far as I believe in the I
remember, this is literally a tars up of
the entire context to the BuildKit daemon.
Can that actually be a meted now if
we're using the type mount targets, or is
that relative still to the build context?
So it's still relative to build context.
But
but
so
what you said was, like, half correct.
So
BuildKit does to,
like, lots of optimizations. For example, like like,
if we if we just, like, had a
copy go mode in here and we didn't
copy anything in our build,
then BuildKit is smart enough. It doesn't it
doesn't, like, tar everything up into giant turbo
like the old builder did.
It it actually, like it pulls the files
when you need them. So the the builder
side will tell you that, hey. I only
need to go mod, and it will basically
adjust, like, fetch to go mod.
Uh-huh. Nice. So so so and and the
same thing works with the updates as well.
Like, basically, like, when you're doing the second
build, the reason
why, like, some of this this is fast
on the second time already is that we
can already BuildKit can already see that that
you uploaded the context one time. And the
next time, it just, like, does, like, a
com comparison and see what files are are
changed and only copies the files that are
changed.
But
it isn't directly, like, looking at your client
desktop. Like, we need to make a snapshot
of the file. So so so, like, when
it's asking that, for example, like, give me
go mod, then we actually make a publication
on the daemon side of of the file.
Because, like, an otherwise, like, if we
like, patching things would happen if you would
allow this file to be mutable.
So we need we need to make a
snapshot of it. That that's the that's the
only caveat. Like, otherwise, it's it's quite smart.
Yeah.
So what what did we get? What's what's
the time of this one? 30 nine seconds
for the build.
So so it's thirty nine for the download
and thirty nine for the
or thirty thirty Thirty point eight for the
download and thirty nine point four for the
build. Yeah. Okay. So so the next one,
like, if you would just want to build
it again, it should be, like, instantaneous.
Right? Because, like, nothing has changed. You can
try this one for a second.
Alright. Let's do it. So we can just
push up and run it. Yeah.
Alright. Nice. It was was pretty fast. And
all the all those
like, it just needed to, like, validate that
some tags are still valid.
Right? That your, like, Alpine has not updated
and and things like that.
Your build context was uploaded in a hundred
milliseconds, but all the all the steps were
cached. Right? So now if you make some
kind of a change
Yeah. For example, yeah, I have to adjust
it. Whatever.
Okay. So let's let's run this locally first
and see how long it takes, and then
we'll do the the container build.
Sure. Sure.
And
time.
That that running the local and then the
container was just like a question that we
had from Russell. He wanted to see if
we could compare the speeds. I expect them
to be
pretty close.
Maybe not as close as I Well,
okay. In here, of course, it depends on
what, like, what your, like like like, your
state was before.
And and also,
like
like, it depends on things like like how
many CPU cores you have enabled in Docker
for Mac and stuff like that as well.
But then that Yeah. There there Like, I
I don't I don't know if if I
I think by default, we don't enable, like
like,
your own machine or something like that. But
but the other guy like that. Yeah. This
I can't remember what my configuration is. It
it should be it should be similar.
So
that was fast. Almost as fast as the
host. Yeah.
So yeah. You're right. That's awesome. And then
I I think it's yeah. Like like
yeah.
Yeah. It it it it's it's it's similar.
It's,
like yeah. It is
like, I I would have hoped it would
be, like, a little bit closer. Like, I
don't know if it's, the CPU settings or
or something like that or or, like like,
it's yeah. It I like the default settings.
Maybe it's an Apple magic a little bit,
but, yeah, like it. Yeah. I should get
an m one, but I'm sure that will
help. But Yeah. Yeah. For sure. For sure.
Yeah. We went from seventy four seconds then
to two point six, and then we were
only five point seven seconds here. But you're
right that, like, my Docker for Mac does
not have access to all my cores. It
doesn't have access to all my memory. It's
constrained. So, you know, that's really close considering
there are those constraints in place. So that's
awesome. I really like The point the point
is that yeah.
Like, theoretically, there shouldn't be much overhead. Like,
if if, like like, like, at least, like,
there shouldn't be overhead from, like, from
the standpoint of,
like, that that doing
getting container is
is less efficient because it can't access some
files or or or or something like that
that the host can access.
So so
the process itself should be should be very
similar
except, of course, like,
everyone gets this like, you just need Docker
to get the same flow all the time
and you don't need any, like, whole setup
or anything like that.
Alright. Awesome. We have a question from Noel
in the chat. He says, with BuildKit, it
doesn't copy over the whole context.
Only thing it needs
only thing that needs to be copied. Does
this mean that the Docker ignore is not
needed when using BuildKit?
Pretty much yet. Like like unless you're doing,
like, copy dot, of course, like, that you
shouldn't be doing.
But, like,
if you're if you're just copying, like, the
specific files that you that you need in
Dockerfile anyway,
then it already works out like a reverse
Docker ignore.
And, also, like like,
you should never use Docker ignore for filtering
your files anyway. Like, you should Docker ignore
is same as ignore. Like, you you
just put files there that are, like, that
that are, like, true or false that you
that you never want to be as part
of your project. Like, if you want to,
like, actually filter, like, some files
from your project, then you use the copy
rules for that.
Alright. Awesome.
So
there was another feature that we kinda spoke
about briefly. I mentioned briefly at the start,
which was the ability to get a binary
out of this so that I can you
access it and run it locally on my
machine. Could we maybe walk through the process
of doing that?
Sure. And it's it's very simple.
I again, like, if you
maybe let let's look at the docs first.
Yeah.
Like,
should go to the BuildKit docs.
So to be the BuildKit tab,
just scroll down a little bit for the
documentation.
You can just, like, write it from the
read me as well. Yeah. So go to
the build command in here. BuildKit build,
and it should be the outputs.
So that's just output.
Yeah. That show.
So so this is just click on the
link for the for the flag.
Yeah. So
so the difference in in
as like a
the the conceptual difference between the BuildKit builder
and BuildKit is that the BuildKit are always
built to Docker images. You always run when
you run Docker build, it will give you
an image back.
BuildKit does not do that. BuildKit just builds
it, and it's left to in your build
cache. Like, the user basically configures
what to
do they want to do with the build
result afterwards.
So it might be that the build result
is is just testing the build cache, might
be the it's turning to an image, might
be that maybe you want to get a
binary back,
wanna get a back. There's, like, different options
in here. So what you wanted is local
binary, so it's the it's the local option
in here.
And but, yeah, you can see that there's
other ones that probably can get the and
and and things like that.
Yeah. In your case,
you you just want the local one. So,
basically, you just want to do, like, dash
show and the directory where you want to
write it.
Like like, I'll take the first example, basically.
Or, like, you probably want to write it
to a Bing directory or something like that.
Okay. So
So
Yeah. I'll do it from the Write write
it, but don't present there yet because I'll
I'll explain it why it's like a little
bit wrong.
Okay. Because I I think what a lot
of people do over the years, and I
see this in Stack Overflow a lot, people
asking questions is that they use Docker
to build their go application, their rest application.
And then normally they run a container and
copy the binary back onto those. This this
removes that whole little hoop jump. Right? So
Abs absolutely. Like like the if you go
back to the
to the,
like, the first Docker file you had where
you copied the the binary. Right? Mhmm. Then,
like, in a very old days where there
was no multistage builds,
then, like, how I built all my all
my stuff, for example, was that I I
needed to have two photographers.
One was like this real
one, and the other one was one that
copied the binary, and then I needed to
do, like
actually,
you couldn't copy out from an image. You
need to create a container from an image
and then copy the binary out from the
container, and then you could use it in
a second build. So, like like, that that's
all gone with multisage builds, that's and and
in this case, where you want to get
just the builder in your host because you
want to run it, like, that will that's
also, like,
that that's fixed by the the show. So
you don't need blocks in here. It's just
like
I guess you you want, like, local being
direct for the first.
And
but the the problem with this one now
would be that
it will
copy out this whole stage, so it will
copy out Alpine as well.
Can we can we copy a single binary,
or is it just
Yeah. Yeah. Of course, you can. So what
you probably want to do in here is
that you want to go from scratch.
Scratch.
So scratch is, a new object in Dockerfile.
Right? Mhmm. So it like, zero layers, nothing.
It's just just new.
We can do
we can do the we can just put
the binary on on the scratch sheet. We
can even, like
or maybe I could better to do this
is to
paint this this stage binary,
and then
if if we just do it by default,
we want to build
Alpine or, like, image based on Alpine, so
we have, like, shell and stuff like that
as well, then
we can do from
binary in here
and in here.
But so so, like, we have a stage
that is from scratch that only contains the
binary.
And then at the last stage, we we
copy all all the binaries that's copied from
from bin.
So
the benefit of maybe this pattern is that,
let's say, you have a second binary as
well,
like, in in
well, whatever. Like, you're you're building three binaries
or something like that. So you can put
them all in here, and then we don't
need to copy paste all the copy steps
in here for,
like, all the three copy steps for every
binary. You can just copy, like, all the
binaries targets.
Okay. Does that mean for our build x
command with the output flag that we've got
pending, do we have to target the the
binary?
Yes. Okay.
I mean, it's just that it depends on
what we choose as default target. Right? Of
course. Like, if if you if I would,
like,
put the binary stage as a last stage
or or, like, just put, like, from binary
in here, then you wouldn't need to do
that. It just depends on you as a
project developer, like, what do you want the,
like, the default Docker build command to do.
Oh, yeah. I think I dropped this and
then make target anyway. Right? So but, really,
I just wanna be able to build that
layer with the scratch and the bin and
then pull that down to here. So does
that command look okay to you? Yeah. Sure.
Press.
Said with such confidence. Let's see. Alright.
Okay. We were a little bit past it
now. Like,
3.8.
So so now
so and that yeah. Now you have the
you have the binary. Right? I built it
for Linux, and now I'm trying to run
it on a Mac. Yeah. There we go.
Exactly.
We'll we'll get to that as well. Right?
Okay.
I like that. But so so but yeah.
Like, this gave you
maybe the final error rate so that you
can
add
so one thing is, of course, like,
if you want to, like, copy those binaries
around,
probably don't want it to be dynamic.
Yeah. You find it on a static binary.
The the
actually, like, the recommendation
I have for, like, all
all time to build go is to just,
like not not to always dis disable seago,
but but to always define what do you
expect the seago value to be.
Because, like especially if you get to, like,
building multi platform targets,
then Go has this
weird logic that, like, your native target is
using seagull by default,
and your other targets are not or other
platforms are not using Sego by default. So
you get, like, a completely different, like, dependencies
depending
on what platform you're building. So I would
just, like, always recommend you to just think
about if your project is using Sego or
not. I I'm not sure if you're project
using using Seagull.
No. I think it should be okay without
Seagull. Yeah. Okay. Then then then this is
the sim simple thing to do.
That that that should take care of this
one as well.
Okay. So shall we move on to will
we try and do multi platform?
Sure.
Will I be able to build a Mac
version and
BuildKit?
We'll see. We'll see. Alright.
If you don't run out of time, then
then yes.
So oh, yeah. That because the SQL enabled
is invalidated or build cache. So But yeah.
That. I'm not sure even sure, like, what
what does it do. Like, if it just
invalidates all build cache or it it's just,
like, because the positive packages has changed. But,
yeah, like, now.
It's It's static. Yeah.
Now now you can copy it to anyone.
So
if we think about multi platform now,
then,
actually, it's like
by default, it's it's very easy.
So you have this command in here. Right?
Mhmm. And I'm not making any changes to
the Docker file at all.
Let me just look at help for a
second.
So there's a platforms flag in here. Right?
Yep.
And
and you can just put, like, the
the
basically, the value of what platform you you
want.
The value is
the format of the value is,
like, OS
arch
and, like, optionally, a variant thing here.
Okay. And and the and the values are
are easy if you come from Go. Otherwise,
like,
every every component in the world defines their
own OS and arch values. So, like, you
just need to look look up what the
what the values are.
And theoretically,
you want what you just
to
do is just put, like, platform in here,
and let's say you will need around 64.
And, basically, you're done. And this actually worked
here and without BuildKit. And and but with
BuildKit,
what you can also do is
okay. My my
screen share doesn't handle this anymore because it
went over some column limit.
So,
basically, you can do, like,
yeah, like, you can share yeah. AMD sixty
four in there as well.
And, like, how do we want to do
this? Can we do Darwin AMD 64?
Not yet because, like, remember
when you
when you we looked at the Docker BuildKit
inspect? Oh, yeah. It had the the platforms,
isn't it? It it had it had, like,
bunch of platforms.
Doesn't have doesn't have Darwin in here because,
like like so these are the, like, the
emulation support that comes with or, like,
that that comes with the Docker desktop.
So we have there's a machine, of course,
supports one native architecture.
But
for other
the binaries, we can just run them through
an emulator,
but with a performance penalty.
So what maybe what we can do in
here is
just try to run this. You will get
an error, and then I will explain the
error.
Exactly. So
so
it would have worked if you just specified
one platform.
But
but because you specified multiple,
then we can't use the Docker driver anymore
because, like, the the whole like, the Docker
image store only handles images for a local
platform. It doesn't handle multiple images,
like, locally.
So what you basically need to do is
run
BuildKit so that BuildKit runs in a different
back end
and and either, like, in Kubernetes or Docker
container.
So,
again, like,
if you want to maybe look at the
docs first or or yeah. Like, basically, you
just do Docker BuildKit's great to use.
So you can you can look at the
go go one step back and look at
the create command.
Alright. So
back from the build build command. Oh, yeah.
That's right. Yeah.
So, yeah, I can grab the driver, for
example. Like, this one explains a little bit
about
the
like, what what
okay. So I'll explain it here. Oh oh,
well, I did may maybe, like, a little
bit down. So,
basically, it's a it's a three types of
drivers that we support at the moment. There
was a Docker container,
Kubernetes,
and and the default that's just using your
Docker daemon.
So for the things like multi platform images
and
and actually for, like, some types of remote
caching,
like local remote cache and and things like
that, you want to use the back end
that's either container or or Docker one. So
but, otherwise, it's like
you can just run the command, and I
will I will, like, show you what what
it what it did in in the back
end.
So you can that that's it. The so
you can use the Docker build XLS now.
You don't have anything there yet.
So now you will see that there's a
there's a new new builder in here. It's
in status inactive.
The the previously, we're using the default builder
with, like, a Docker driver. Now we're using
the Docker container driver. So what you can
do is Docker build, like, inspect
and just put that's just bootstrap in there.
That's that's you don't actually need to run
this command to build stuff. You could just
run build at the moment, but let me
let's just show you what it what it
how it comes up. So we would that's
just bootstrap.
Yeah.
So now we're just, like, telling to build
that. Just just put it so don't build
anything. Just just put itself.
Okay. Whenever we use
the Docker container
driver, we get a different container with BuildKit
for the architecture that you want to build
for.
Not not for the architecture you want to
build in. Just just one container that
but that that build that container now contains
full BuildKit, so it has the full capabilities,
for example, for the multi platform stuff. So
this this one can can manage the multi
platform images and things like that. So, yeah,
now you can see that it's running. You
can run the LS again,
for example.
You can see that it still supports your
platforms. Right?
And
and
if you do that container LS
or Docker PS,
then you should see the the the container
as well. Like, yeah, like, this is where
the actual, like, the container is running.
BuildKit is inside that
inside that container.
And and now when you run new builds,
this is actually where your builds will happen.
Okay. So now we can We can run
run that on the same build build again
with the two platforms.
Okay. So, you know, you're Yeah. You do
a lot of Go development. Right?
So, like, would you lean on BuildKit and
multi platform, or would you lean on Go's
kind of cross platform build? Like, is there
a difference there? Is there a preference?
What what do you mean? Do you ask
for, like, a with with a with a
lean on, like, the course cross compiling? Yeah.
Would you use go build with cross compilation
to different architectures, or do know do you
think the build can
Abs absolutely. Like, all our project use the
cross compilation, and and
I would show you, like, how how to
do this as well. But I just want
to, like,
show, like this is, the this is, like,
the first way
Okay. That basically to do this. Like like,
remember,
like, we didn't make any changes to a
Docker file. Right?
Like, the like, the Dockerfile was just, like,
built for a single platform.
And and we only thing we basically say
is, like, yeah, like, okay. Like, now give
me give me an image for a different
platform or give me a multi platform image,
and it does work out of the box.
What
so at the moment, you can see, for
example, that, yeah, it's it's running the, like,
it's running the go build command at the
moment,
and you can see that it's actually running
two times. Right? Yep. So one one one
is running natively like you did before. You
don't get previous cache at the moment for
this build because you're in a container now.
So you will get the co cache again
for the for the next one because you
because you switched the back end, then then
you lost that cache. Yeah. That makes sense.
So
so this is
so this variant
is super simple. Right? No no changes.
Obviously, like, one of them is running in
an emulator, so it has a performance penalty.
And
I was saying ARM 64 one's gonna take
a little bit longer than the AMD sixty
four. Yes. Yes.
Like, I would maybe expecting here may maybe,
like, three, four times longer.
Alright. So so
so
especially,
like, it depends on what your Docker file
is doing.
So if you're, like, installing packages,
like, for example, you are from Alpine installing
packages,
absolutely no problem to run this in emulator.
It will take, like, hundred milliseconds natively, and
it will take, like, hundred and fifty in
emulator.
Like, if there's no there's no CPU intensive
things in there,
Like, it's absolutely fine to run this in
an emulator.
Like, if
you're doing compilation of of, like, big code
bases,
then you will really see, like, where this
emulator thing will will start to, like, hurt
you. And and but we'll see, like,
given that it didn't require any any
changes in the Docker file,
like,
you will not build this, like, every time
you make a code change. Right? Every time
you make a code change, you will you
will build that previous one that that that
we had, like, running back in three seconds
or something like that. Mhmm. Like, if this
runs, like, one time in your CI, like,
maybe it's even fine. Like, I I I
would say, like, like, we don't use this
one. I would I will next show you,
like, what we use.
But I
think most people who use BuildKit today use
this one because, like like,
the the
like, multiple platform build, the transient CI, yeah,
it takes, like, three times longer. Like like,
we like,
the the it it doesn't slow them down
down as well. Like like, the those builds
don't happen that often.
Okay.
I guess we've got about another minute before
this one. I hope this finishes.
Look. May maybe if you go to back
to the browser,
I can talk a little bit about
so you got this for free because you're
using Docker Desktop. Right? Yes.
So
so what
that means is that
when
in your Docker Desktop VM, you already have
the
the emulators installed in the kernel, basically, of
the of the of the VM.
So every time we we make that
we make a builder, it's just like you
can see that they support six platforms. Why
it supports six platforms is because they're already
like, the emulators are loading in in a
kernel.
If you're not
in the in the same system,
then you actually need to to one more
step.
I'm copying to the link.
You need to actually load the emulators.
So if you go to that link,
you can you can actually see, like, how
you would
how you would set up those emulators if
you don't have them in the system. And
it's very simple. It's just a Docker image.
So if you scroll down a bit,
like like,
basically,
you just run the run the install command
in there, and you can just say that's
just install all.
And then and
then it will it will load all those
emulators
from this image to your kernel, and you
have the same experience every time. So for
example, like,
in the CI system or something like this,
may maybe you want to run this beforehand
to make sure that you're
that
that you have have those on. And then
it will show you what what's all supported
for your biosystem and what what the model
does she have installed.
Okay. So,
basically, she just uses QMU then, and you
can just install your own platforms if required
into the BuildKit container using
this tool. And and, doc, this is the
QMU.
So so this is, like, the the QMU
needs to be in kernel,
then BuildKit can use it. Right. Okay.
So so, basically, like, once you install use
this command,
it will install the emulate. It will enable
QMU basically in your kernel. And then when
you do, like, build x inspector, build x
l s, you will see that BuildKit finds
all all those emulators for you.
Right. Right. Okay. That makes sense.
Nice. Okay. Did our build figure it out
or not?
It's still not. It's still thinking. But
why don't we
I mean, there were a few sub commands
here. Right? And we've not covered
all of them. Maybe we could what what
does the bake subcommand do?
So so bake
well, bake task is basically, like, for example,
like, when you the command you're running at
the moment. Right? Like, the the binary
like,
you you're running a command that's doing a
build. It sets a target to binary.
It sets the output to local.
It sets the platforms to do platforms.
Right?
And you need to you need to remember
it somewhere. Like, you need to, like, put
it in a make file or something like
that.
So what bake is that
it allows you to create this high level
targets that already, like, contain your your specific
configuration.
Like, for for example, like, you can you
can say that binary target for my project
means that I'm I'm building a binary target.
I'm putting in a test and pip inform
format. I'm building it for two platforms.
You can write this all in a big
file, and then you can can run Docker
build ex big binary,
and it will be all taken care of.
It's like it feels like a little bit
like Make. Right? Yeah. Like, that's where the
where the name comes from. Right? But
it can do, like, things that Make can't
do. Right? Because, like like, in Make, you
would
you would need to if you're building, like,
front multiple targets, for example,
like, make and figure out that those targets
can actually build in parallel and stuff like
that
that that BuildKit can figure out. If you
just go back to the bin format project,
I believe bin format project uses uses
bake Yeah. There was a And and
bake like, this is HCL. Like, it doesn't
need to be HCL. Like, it can be
just a composed file or, like or even,
like, the language is a little bit, like
like,
not not not that important in here. But,
yeah, you can see, like, we we have
some, like, nice yeah. Exactly. Like, the the
binaries thing is exactly like like like
explained
here in here. So so in in this
project, you could basically just do big binaries,
and it will figure out what what to
do.
And we have some, like, weird targets in
here. Like like, some on my projects have,
like, the linters and, like, for example, you
have the tox generation and the, like, the
vendor generation.
Like, they can all be, like, defined as
as, like, a big targets. Then in the
end, you can have, like, a group that
just say, like, pre commit or something like
that. And that that just, like, runs all
all of them in parallel, all the all
the validation logic in in parallel. This one
is a little bit complicated because, like, there's,
like,
variants of it and and, like so there's,
we have, like, a bunch of configuration options
that go, like, build different versions of those
emulators and stuff like that. So but that
that's basically it.
So finally, four hundred and fifty seconds.
Yes.
So take a bit of time, but we
got there.
To prove the point that
that if you're running your peak compilation step,
then maybe emulators is not the way to
go. Unless you're running like that, build once
a day, like, then whatever. But are they
are those both cached now?
Yes. Okay. So so first of all, like,
you can look at their bin directory now
and you you have multiple binaries there.
Oh, yeah.
Look at that. So
yeah. So you you should have the ARM
64 binary. You can just, like, test it
in the file. Just show
that it's there.
Typing. But, yeah, we'll get there.
Yeah. So r two q four.
Very cool.
So
I we we can I could just copy
that target like I did there and create
a Docker dash bake.htl
and then just run Docker bake
target
and that should still all be cached and
just does the exact same command that we
ran? Absolutely. Absolutely.
Alright. I just I wanna see it.
Okay. You said there were multiple formats. So
h e HCL is one format, and there's
Docker Well, I want there's we can just
do we can if you have it just
like a composed file, you can just do,
like, a, like,
with a compose target as well.
Okay.
Let me replicate this.
Copilot's
ticket.
There we go.
And we want to target the binary target
and our container
and open as Ben. So I think that's
the same defined in HCL as we have
in the command line. Is that?
Yeah. It's pretty much it. So you you
can you also do I'm not oh, the
target no. Wait. That's the tag is local
target. Yeah. Okay. That's the same, I think.
You can also do
group default.
Yeah. I've seen that in in your files.
Why don't I just Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. So
And then just match this.
So with this, instead of that big long
Docker build x, we can do build x
base. First of all, you you can do
it like a big just to touch the
print, for example, for for just like a
test.
That's this will show you, like, what what
is going to be built. Sorry. That's that's
test? Print. Print. Print. Sorry. Yeah.
What's wrong?
What's the name of the file?
Docker dash bit. But it's Oh, okay. Oh,
no. I've it in the wrong Oh, you
got it in the wrong directory, I think.
There
we go. So so, yeah, now now it
will show you exactly what it's going to
build.
And, yeah, like, if you remove print, then
it will just run on the on the
build for you. And you can of course,
like, the the command line takes the targets
as as arguments. So you can do, like,
binary,
full bar, and, like, every everything. Like, you
can do, like, like, million targets together as
well.
Okay. So it used
the build cache on our AMD sixty four.
Hopefully,
ARM 64 is just gonna be about thirty
seconds.
And it should still have cache. Like like
like, GoCache should still do that. Like, you
There we go. Okay. Okay.
Didn't take that one.
So it did Alright. Three times as long
as as the as the making one.
K. I like that big fail and just
making all declarative and getting that. Like, yeah,
I could write a make target, but maybe
just use it. You can do, like
in the HCL syntax, you can do, like,
weirdnesses,
like like, define variables and, like, functions and,
like, we can, like little bit, like, have,
like, a macro style in there to have
it, like, more configurable as well. Like like,
this is, a
a project level logic. It would maybe put
in a big file that, like, defines, like,
this is, like, a different configurations of how
your project is supposed to be built and
stuff like that. In in Dockerfile, maybe you
have, like, more generic things like co version
and stuff like that that are, like, that
are, like,
universal for all the projects.
Yeah. We got a comment from Crazy Max
talking about some of the things that they're
doing with big, so building boundaries, multi platform
image, generate docs, lens, update, validate vendors, generate
progress and test the app all in a
big definition.
So that's pretty cool. If you've got a
link Crazy Max to one of your projects
that does that, I'd love to see the
HCL at some point. So please share.
And no other comments saying that they love
conditionals and bake.
So cool. Lots of options there.
Alright.
We've we've covered an awful lot here. Is
there anything that we've missed before we finish
up? Do you think would be really cool
to share with people?
Mean Put you on the spot. Like, what
what have we forgotten?
I mean, what what we've forgotten is is
the, like, the cross compilation. I'm not sure
if it if you can push through it
with ten minutes or or not. Like like,
that that's that's what was for your question
of, like, what's the alternative for QMU and
what's the
and what's the
like, how you can get a Darwin target?
Like, we can try to answer that if
you if you if you can push through
it. Well, yeah, why don't we make a
start on it? If we feel that we're
not gonna get through it in time, we'll,
you know we can we can leave it.
If we're almost there, we can always run
a little bit over. We we can see
it. Or if you want, we can leave
it for another day. I'll I'll leave the
decision in your hands, Todus.
Okay. Let let's try it. Okay. So That's
good.
What we basically, what we want to do
in gross computation
is if you look at this article file
again,
Yeah. Post your link just
yeah.
The link I posted to you is how
I do gross compilation and how, like, Docker
projects do the gross compilation.
So that that one is, like, a little
bit advanced. We will probably not go go
to this one. But this one has, like
a first section is is has, like, a
introduction to cross compilation.
So, yeah, like like this cross compilation primary.
So,
basically, what the best way to do this
is that we have this certain
automatic arguments in Docker files that we just
provide from the builder. Like, you can even
click on the link to automatic platform arcs
in GlobalScope.
Yeah. So this is the Docker documentation. So,
basically, all those arguments
are available
to you
automatically inside a Dockerfile. We just define the
arc, and we will figure out what the
correct value is.
So, basically, if you're building for, like, an
like, a PowerPC, for example, we will put
target platform equals PowerPC target OS equals Linux,
Arch equals PowerPC.
Okay. And and then you can use this
one in to
to have, like, some stages be native to
your current platform,
some stages to be
individual for your target platform. Right?
So if you go back then now then
so the easiest way to do this in
a cross compilation thing is that in this
first stage, we we say
that,
oh, there's a there's a massive mistake in
this example. It's not supposed to be from
Dash's from. It's supposed to be from Dash's
platform.
Ah, okay.
So so Her request welcome.
Yeah.
So so it's, like,
from
and you say that this this stage is
always for the build platform. So you say
platform equals build platform,
and then this stage will always be the
same. Even if you if you build for
ARM and and you build for AMD, it
will always be AMD in your case because
you're
I believe you were an x 86 machine.
Right?
Mhmm. Yep. So so it will always be
the same. It will always be the same
command. And then when you define a target
platform, now the compile step is different
because it
the target platform value is different. So the
so the Alpine image was built one time
and then compiles
command run two run two times with a
different argument to the dashes target.
And so now we have two binaries, and
now we have the second stage, Alpine, that
doesn't have any dashes platform flag.
So now this this stage is is separate
again for for every platform,
and we're just copying the binary to that
stage.
Okay. Make a bit sense.
Yeah. I think that makes sense. Yeah.
So, basically, in your case, like, I'm I'm
I switch back to code now.
Okay. So you're adding the from platform
to our first part.
Yeah. So, basically, like, in here, you could
like, if you're stupid, then you can write
something like this. Like but but, like, let's
not do that. Right?
It will it will be the same value,
but
but,
like,
this one, then you can use you can
cross compile from from ARM as well.
So and in this case, like like, dependencies,
we can only pull one time as well.
Like, we don't care about pulling them twice.
Right? Mhmm.
And now in here, we can just do
target
OS,
target arch.
So just to define those arguments so that
they're now available.
Of course, the code supports cross completion super
easily.
Yeah. We can just do a target OS
in here.
The large
equals
target
arch,
And I think that's it.
Okay. Let's try.
Alright. So So you can you can just
run the run the same pay pay command
again. Yeah. Just nothing changes. That's it. Alright.
Now now you can already see, like, the
the go image only one time in here.
Previously, it was it was
multiple times.
And now
now you understand why the one one miscached.
Right? The other the other one isn't because,
like, the the
your
any of the 64 notes did not have
the RNCache yet.
Okay.
Right.
Okay. It it make a little bit sense.
But but now, like like, if you if
you run this if you make make a
code change now and you run it run
this again,
Okay. So
Okay. So so six seconds in total. Like,
that's okay. Three for each pointer.
So so now you have a
you're building for multiple platforms
with with the same speed that you had
before.
Yeah. So there there there was a change
there. It only happened in the Dockerfile, and
I I wanna make sure I understand this
correctly. Sure. Right? As previously, before we added
the platform to the from here and the
ARC for the target OS,
we were using different container images with QEM
emulation to compile the things within the different
containers.
But Docker
or BuildKit seems to be smart enough to
work out that if I have a platform
from with these args things here that it
can do that same compilation
compilation in the same container.
So But it's no longer using the the
second
QMU
and the BuildKit.
Is that right? So so the so the
first thing to understand in here is that
the whole, like, like, the BuildKit design is
like deep application. Right? So you're building, like,
two targets in parallel. They share some parts.
Like, BuildKit, we just, like, optimize them together.
Like, it's it's like it's one of the,
like, the key key principles of the design.
So so, like, to
to be efficient,
the first step is to not run the
code that's useless. Right? So it will always
detect those things that
if if your two builds share some some
components,
then it will combine them together. Now in
this case, for example,
let's say you're building for the
for the ARM target.
I this stage started before there was the
Dashes platform flag in here. Mhmm. Though those
commands would have been different. One of those
commands would have been get me a colon
image for AMD sixty four, and the other
one would have been get me colon image
for ARM sixty four. Yeah. Now because because
they're all both fixed to the build platform,
now they're both saying, give me a colon
image for AMD sixty four. And BuildKit will
instantly, like, notice that, like, hey. Like, those
two builds are they're using the same image,
so they're the same command.
And and and then it's just like, for
example, once they go more download in here,
it still understands that those those two
commands are the same command that runs on
top of same image, so they're the same.
Yes. It it's like that. Step but the
compilation step is not is not same. Right?
Because the compilation step has those two different
environment variables,
so that command is not equal anymore.
Okay. So I'm just gonna make this special
for other people in case because it it
took a little bit moment for me. But
when these were a metered, what we actually
had were multiple steps
like this.
However, when we or when you made that
change to say use the build platform,
we actually reduced
the instructions that that was sent to BuildKit,
which is why it can do those jobs
as it did. Okay. That makes a lot
of sense now. I got it. So so,
yeah, like, let's say that if you were
building this Alpine target in here, like, in
line 17 still,
like, then
then previously,
we would have pulled two Golang images and
two Alpine images.
Mhmm. Right? With now with this change, we're
pulling one Golang image only.
We run the compiler always on one Golang
image, and then but we still have two
Golang images. Right? Because in the end, like,
we want to push the
e v 64 image based on e v
64 Alpine and and, like, the busy box
in that image will be will will come
from different images.
Got it.
Very nice. I like that.
And we did it at time. Right?
Yeah. So
one one thing that was different thing well,
first of all, let's check your Darmin.
So just just
put the run the same command, but put
your that's just platform, put Darmin in 64
there.
Because now there's no reason for the Darwin
not to work.
Sorry. Can you say that again? I missed
it.
That's in the in the Dutch platform.
You can So an HTML.
Yeah.
In here You want to add the Darwin?
Yeah. You can even, like, remove the other
ones because, like, I guess for the default,
like, you just want your local one. Right?
Yeah. You can just try this one. Oh,
okay.
Okay. So this okay.
Yeah. This works because of the build platform
on the frontline, which always builds the AMD
sixty four or whatever my build platform is,
and then relies on the Google cross compilation
by setting the target OS and the target
arch, which is why Exactly. I got it.
I I I do but you want you
understand why it didn't work before. Right? Yes.
Because, a first step, like, it didn't even
doesn't even reach to QMU. It's like
the pillar would say, like, give me a
Darwin in the 64 image for Golang. And,
of course, there's no such thing. Like, there's
no Darwin Darwin image there. Like, that that
that's why it doesn't work.
Finally. Yeah. I'm I'm obviously just picking this
up a little bit slow, but I got
it. That's awesome. So now for languages like
go and rust where cross compilation is available
with the compiler tool chain, you can really
build some pretty nice
build pipelines with bake and HCL and BuildKit.
I think that works really well.
Cool. Yeah. And and and and so
now you can try to run this one.
Like, this one, just bin blocks
should should run-in our machine. Right?
Well Yeah. The same command.
Oh, sorry. Your It's not gone. Yeah.
Yeah. It's it's this one because you only
built a single platform. It it's configurable, actually,
like, if you if you don't want it.
Yeah. It works.
And the
last thing
Yeah. What
was the like, if you remember in in
my project, there wasn't already named six four
in there. There was just local. So local
is just like a hack thing
in the in the in the in the
in in format projects when you where you
copy the big file.
Yeah. That one. Like, I I had local
in here. Ah, so anyone that wants to
build the binary, they can just use that
local. So local is just like a magic
platform value that is, like, if I'm copying
if I'm running your big file,
I'm on ARM, then it will mean tarry
in ARM 64 for me. If, like, Linux
person is is running big on their machine,
it will it will mean whatever,
like, their system is. So if you want
to just local binary, then you would use
this one instead of instead of hard coding
in
the 64.
It will be exactly the same binary in
the end. Okay. So I can just
Local.
Yeah. It's okay.
I guess that's all
I'll go back,
and that should be pretty instant. Right? So
And yeah. And if you want to get,
like, further into this, then this project, this
XX project
is, like, what I use, like, for more
complicated
cross compilation flows. Like, for example, you can
imagine, like, at the moment, we have the
SQL enabled SQL zero in your in your
build. Right? Like, let's say, we you need
c go enabled equals one,
then it's not so simple to do cross
compilation anymore. Right?
So
like, the c cross compilation tool chain is
way harder than than
than go cross compilation tool chain.
And
this this project basically makes it easy. So,
like, any anyone interested, like, can can look
at just follow the examples in here. Like,
there's examples in here how to how to
build c and, like and once you set
up c, then then
then you'll automatically have c go and and
things like that.
What was that? And, like, how how to
install packages and, like, you you can, like,
basically, like
like
I hope, like, for for most, like, c
c and
co project, like,
they should this basically is like a almost
like a drop in. So we just, like,
drop drop this into your into your build
stage and and basically the same simple things
that you had in Go. Like, this works
for the different languages as well.
Awesome. Alright. I'll include a link to this.
I think people should check it out. Just
see some of this. So there's the the
Go example there. So Yeah.
Alright. Cool.
So this is what we actually use in
all our projects. We just, like, drop this
into our Docker file, and and then we
have those
those million exported targets. Like, if you look
at, like like, BuildKit itself, like, it's all
built from Dockerfile.
It's built into, like, I don't know, 10
platforms or something like that,
and it's and it's all through this.
Nice. Very, very cool.
Alright.
Anything else? Are you happy with that?
Like Sure. Good question. Pig supports Compose. It
like, yes. It does support support Compose.
Okay. Yeah. So question,
it would because of Pig could support Compose
spec.
YAML, is that different from Docker Compose?
No.
It's just like like
you can you can use
like, if you have a composed file,
you can you can, of course, build it
with the compose itself as well. You can
also just directly build it with BuildKit.
Can just do basically that. If you do
BuildKit, you have a Compose file in the
directory. It will just build all your Compose
services with bake in parallel and everything. All
all the goodness with that one. Or you
can, like, choose a a composed service
from your composed file same as your you
had your binary target in here.
Right. And we got a question from Noel
asking, does XX use BIN format magic?
So no.
It so bin format is the QEM emulation.
Right? Bin format is actually like the like
the bin format misc is like the kernel
feature that allows loading emulators. That's why it's
called bin format. So bin format is the
emulation side if you want to if you
want to add emulation, if you take the
performance penalty, but what no changes in your
Docker file, excess excess cross compilation.
So that's
that's that's for defining the
if if you're if you're going through the
cross compilation route, then XX makes it easy
to build c projects and CMake and and
all those things.
Alright. Awesome. I don't think we have any
more questions.
I have learned an absolute metric ton today
looking at BuildKit and BuildX. So thank
you for walking us through this, Thomas.
Really, really cool projects. I'm looking forward to
adopting
more Docker files aren't just copying them a
binary. Think we've cleaned up Thank
I think we've cleaned up my the QBox
project really nicely. I'm looking forward to sending
that PR to Brian and getting him to
take a look at it.
So very, very cool. Yeah.
A couple of thanks coming in the chat,
I'll throw them up in the intro. Thomas,
thank you so much. That was fantastic.
So thank you for spending there your afternoon
with us.
Thank you. Alright. Have a great day. Bye
all.